Justin a big victory for you with the
black pieces first of all
congratulations uh tell us about this
game this particular moment you came up
with this idea against Queen tweet to
try Target your knight on A6 rookie 8
and E5 were you surprised when he fell
into your trap with Queenie too I don't
know I was not even like
uh like only on the move I was thinking
like seriously about E5 like I like
before I did not
like yeah only after Queen YouTube I
mean like before it was not like I
seriously calculated E5 bits here I
thought it was an option and I mean the
other option is in the united B8 but
I mean that's a bit too passive I don't
know for your taste right at this point
so you play D5 this best move in the
position by fast move no best move in
the position by far and you obtained the
priests
moving upon but yeah yeah no this this
one was winning for you and but he
fought his way back
did you feel like that as well I think I
missed like probably I should not have
taken the pawn you which is probably too
risky so I think uh like this maybe oh
yeah like some some point I should play
Queen C7 here yes Queen C7 instead of
yeah
instead of taking it on C3 no there is
definitely then you cannot move any
pieces here I think ice is the position
and then Queen also can go to E5 so I'm
not sure I'm not sure why I do not play
this and if he goes H5 yeah
Rook C3 is like kind of on the wrong
track I guess it gives him too much
comfortably right yeah
then you take take H6 what are you
starting to get concerned at this point
I mean I started to get concerned after
maybe like age six already is I was not
sure Queen takes H6 yeah I've been
Knight D5 and then queen c65 queen takes
E5 again
it looks like someone yeah this one is
starting to get wild yeah
maybe I should have just played that but
I don't know yes
yeah it's just losing okay well it's
quite an engine and then they smooth
Queen to f5k you know do you think he
what what did he make sure what's going
on here like I was not even like I did
not even see Rook takes G2 for until I
until it was that move like
well I thought it was a draw at some
point but it could be a drop it's just I
also have this British G2 resource okay
I think I'm lucky to have it but I
thought like after Queen G4 yeah I'm not
sure like maybe he should not have taken
the pawn but no it seems like right yeah
this was I mean everything is
everything is more clear with the onions
of course yeah yeah 96 I don't know yeah
it's it's a completely wild position
right yeah everything is hanging this
King on E8 where is he going yeah no
wild position he mismanaged it and yeah
here's
yup yeah and then after that you just
converted nicely Justin congratulations
an important victory for you do you know
Jason at all have you met him before or
was this the first time you guys made I
don't know like met him and I mean I've
seen him before I've now played him as
the first time
[Music]
it's your first time yeah
good well congratulations on your
Victory a very important one thanks
congratulations as well that leaves us
with one single gaming